per l'estetica cemento che sono bravi j
ag siamo tornati i suoi più parti
ragazzi questa c'era il cavo che mi dà
fastidio non solo rincretinito tutto
d'un tratto forse più che ragazzi
cominciamo per chiudere cook kirby sram
page
cos'è enjoy cooking vita ok ok perché
c'è kirby in questa cosa mi manca a
possono uscire la gente visto che non
ascolta azione via no no a fermo per
ferro ascolta comprendo non arrivava mai
dai già provato ma è troppo più quel
giorno sconti le pen
mi dispiace io non dubiterei mai ragazzi
della bravura di kirby a cucinare perché
bravissimo comunque capire questo salti
in padella mi sembra quattro salti in
barella prova da più o meno battuta
pessima tra vinto se questo non so chi
tu sia ma se veramente un figo fatelo
dire comunque complimenti per kirby che
sa cucinare ultimate bmx questo sì
assolutamente sì
sei pronto youth tt vedo pronto sei nato
pronto sogno che cazzo abbiamo combinato
sono ancora viva ma [ __ ] dai
veramente mi sembra una presa per il
culo st livello
complimenti liu che avrà bravo è una
roba di no dove vai dove cazzo ma ecco
infatti andato più avanti lui alla fine
luca era quello messo peggio e le colo
rimasto vivo ok un ragazzo io c'ho
veramente il pene piccolo a parte gli
scherzi c'è veramente il presentimento
che più vado avanti in happy meals più
le cose diventano senza senso perché non
è possibile
ok ok ok abbiamo fare dal punto di prima
abbia superato perfetto
è stato tragico provi intorno al boom
facciamo questo gli ha impedito sagra
grazie ascoltare ancora scotta liu che
già possiamo fare non ce la faremmo mai
però la donna è partito e partite vince
ho vinto io io che abbiamo vinto né culo
[Musica]
mi ha finito già basta sia roma basta
quanti altri ucciso figo ma in questo è
figo calibra ho vinto ho vinto tutto
l'epicità sparate di questo ok o
leggermente marchiato il traguardo forse
però eh vabbè checa che cosa è una
posizione yoga questa donna moderna
l'ho presa l'ho presa però ce l'avevo
giocare questa bomba perché sono non
vincerò mai però non capisco di me lo
devo mettere nel culo uomo a propulsione
in arrivo sì ci ho fatto caso non è
possibile però cosa ho fatto
cosa fa cosa stai facendo steel 2 3 l'ho
preso
[Musica]
alcune persone hanno il proprio accesso
privato ragazzi io sono una di quelle io
non ce la faccio senza io c'ho lo
stimolo così così credete
ecco vedete che funziona mio dio va bene
[ __ ] wars fight for families by
paul è venuto questo ragazzo già ci sono
fattori prima mi sto morendo dentro
invece sia come non c'è verso regalo
annuncia oggi proprio viceversa situate
verso manco a morire invece sì
come ho fatto a spezzargli una gamba che
sono caduti ai 300 all'ora be my lorido
forza sì sì [ __ ] aiuti serve bene vai
così c'è e ci ho messo anni anche qui
prova vendevano test ma buongiorno si
faccia su che mi hai parcheggiato in
doppia fila
triumph ma ci sono altre che [ __ ] testo
livello ma posso sforare con tutte le
armi a very powerful calibro 45 magnum
bribon predicato zio non mi piace
chi va se prendiamo un caffè ma vera
gara tengo io ho capito ma chi sono
bella non ho mai visto una pistola casey
molecola una persona è però va bene
bella la descrizione bravo mi inchino
ascolto mi sono sono riuscito a
sbloccarmi con l'inchino fantastico e
questo sai dove tono di ficcare giro sai
dove da modificare il tuo problema è
aver creato luke fratello sono avessi
fatto saresti ancora vivo ok bene
abbiamo mi è partita una gamba va bene
step gran cosa sta roba press backwards
sei un [ __ ] genio non so chi è stato
a questo livello ma è un [ __ ] genere
la partenza è stata epica ragazzi ci
siamo è partito io che mai un cazzo che
è successo è morto nostro vivo ho visto
cosa è successo ho capito una sei
fantastico è stato figo dottore in 2015
lui l'ha fatto dal futuro questa ragazza
è bellissimo
ok soli sono vivo non l'ho capita
sinceramente questa ve la fate capire un
attimo ad adesso sono morto mi segreto è
non ne sono sicuro bello pianisti pieni
sì l'ho preso ti ho preso si arrivi a
dio via nievo via ottimo via già faccio
già abbiamo fatta ce l'abbiamo fatta
così io sono seduto in un modo
comodissimo è fantastico chi ce l'abbia
fatta fabio fabene ancora una madonna
che botta michael jackson sarebbe fiero
di te amico via
[Musica]
e stato fantastico tanto ancora sì sì sì
sì ok desolei temi più bello allegro
ragazzo è un posto per bambini questa
partenza è buona ragazzino svago non qua
perché tanto non serve a niente era
bello solo perché piangi vorrei che io
che l'ho lasciato indietro se n'è andato
a trovarlo elia pedofilo e di te li
facciamo perché non capendo aiuti devi
toglierti dalla mia terra ecco bravo
perché non hai capito ragazzi lui non
riesce a capire l'importanza ti devi
togliere dalla meta senti bimba fammi
fondo ai prendi lui
prendi lui ti prego ti scongiuro prendi
lui niente
ok perfetto ce l'ho fatta ragazzi ci ho
messo un'ora però a fare il suo pezzo
che non morivo sempre ok
devo andare donato si qua 5 dopo io c'ho
no non secco bravo mi ha lasciato solo
vivo ancora perfetto poi friends allora
ascoltavi io ho lasciato uk indietro
vabbè prenditi le mie gambe sarei
contento uguale credo altro christmas o
addirittura perché per natale ora me
belle queste dovrebbero essere palle di
natale questa non ci va beh non importa
ci vivo di boltro sono troppo forte
l'ultima volta e poi basta perché se non
c'è e basta
sappiamo tutti che sono il campione
indiscusso al mondo di purtroppo quindi
non c'è bisogno social social devo fare
che figo che è figo a me il pallone
d'oro se sto facendo quei due con state
facendo regali
dov'è il fair play ma anche a suarez che
dal morso che gol che i gol della nato
nato l'altro mi sto calando troppo
cos'è appena successo regalati o un
attimo ecco questi sono infortuni che
capitano spesso enel che guarda lo gol
questo è un gol validissimo alzato in
piscina è pacchia
va beh eccolo ecco è questo si chiama
assalto del nord ho fatto una cosa epica
ho preso una bolla che bello allen allen
sheikh per fa vj cosa vuol dire al lecce
bene bene sarà un mio livello nella
classifica mondiale di happy bis
e così ci faranno tutti un'idea della
madonna di chi sono sono convinto sono
una rock come fa ad avere risparmi sotto
i valli d'addio amico mio
ole ole ole ole fiumana di ma la voglio
sapere perché mi fate cosa sta faccia
ragazzi è un alieno è una è un [ __ ]
polipi hard jump questo devo fare il
salto difficile devo andare lì e cioè ma
secondo me non è tanto di credo e non
preso salandra alla quale c'ero quasi
come ho fatto a mangiarlo lo so cioè ha
vinto il mio poco e non ho vinto io
cerin ci rendiamo conto di vista cosa
niente ora che non ci arrivo per un mini
ma è possibile ora che schifo l'ho preso
stavolta lo presta volta dovete metterlo
nel didietro accordo ragazzi faccio
ancora troppo al per fa vj ma perché ci
sono i miei livelli
classifica mondiale braga siete
fantastici se riusciamo a finire in
classifica mondiale con i nostri livelli
dove sono i metalli dove obama che mi dà
le medaglie dove è una roba
vai così guarda che riguardava guarda ma
la propaggine dove la mettiamo anche
ragazzine che posso concludere qui fa
vigesse in questo mio secondo livello
sei un grande ma avevo letto grazie di
cuore
mastercard tu sei fantastico amico mio
perché i beni ribelli non si possono
comprare ma per tutto il resto c'è
mastercard questa battuta di merda
merito linciaggio e lo so tutti ragazzi
dire che posso concludere qui il video
sei video è piaciuto non sento lasciato
punto mi piace al capo gianni facebook e
come ogni video trovata descrizione dei
siti simmetrici vediamo il prossimo
video vede ragazzi